it is a battle commonly fought in
private and unfortunately sometime
leading to death in our Valley domestic
violence now the problem actually grew
across the country during the pandemic
and here in Nevada it happens one in
every four women and one in every seven
men in their lifetime Ryan mathie
joining us now live in studio tonight
for more details about domestic violence
Awareness Month yeah Brian Denise you
may have seen purple all month for this
awareness like here at the Palazzo Hotel
domestic violence is going down
Statewide but officials say those
numbers are deceiving because many
victims choose to not speak up about it
and while some locals live or local
lives have been lost because of it
survivors are trying to get those
fighting alone to come to the light
I was awakened by my service dog uh
Licking me in the face and I was in a
pool of blood a hostage in her own home
that's how Shekinah Johnson describes
the past three years of her life I have
PTSD and my heart is compassionate to
help others and I don't wish that hurt
or harm or danger my worst enemy
because nobody could fathom that type of
thing beaten to the Bone emotionally and
financially manipulated and cut off from
the world she found the strength to get
out but not everyone does she's one of
over 1600 domestic violence cases
reported in Nevada just this year Metro
Police reports 17 incidents ending in
Murder this year tied for the leading
cause of homicides in its jurisdiction a
lot of victims still get shamed Linda
Perez is a survivor of domestic abuse
and president of shade tree Nevada's
only 24 7 emergency shelter for domestic
abuse and human trafficking victims her
staff and clients gathered their
Thursday to honor those lost and those
surviving
the names of those lost repeated and
never forgotten and while domestic abuse
reports are the lowest they have been
Statewide since 2019 the real numbers
may never truly be known they're in a
relationship where that's supposed to be
the person that protects them and loves
them and that's pretty pretty much what
they know
now taking the first step is the hardest
part they say the number you see on your
screen right now is their emergency
crisis hotline and we have many more
resources on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live in studio Ryan Matthey 8
News Now